notre grand témoin je vous le disais
Mathilde panot qui a une actualité
chargée cette semaine avec la réforme
des retraites évidemment une défaite
électorale pour la France insoumise en
arrière et des critiques qui se font
jour au sein de la nuque mais si on vous
invite Mathilde panot ce n'est pas
seulement pour parler de cela
explication de Marco pommier
si on vous invite Mathilde panneau c'est
parce que vous êtes en première ligne
contre la réforme des retraites à
quelques jours de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel
farouche opposante à Emmanuel Macron
dans la rue comme à l'Assemblée
le président et ses ministres n'avait
autant et délibérément menacé la paix
civile du pays qu'il gouverne Emmanuel
Macron fait honte à la France applaudi
par les vôtres les 74 députés insoumis
sous votre houlette à la tête de la
France insoumise depuis 2021 vous êtes
la plus jeune présidente d'un groupe à
l'Assemblée Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne tarit
pas d'éloches sur votre personne une
trajectoire fulgurante députée du
Val-de-Marne vous faites vos premiers
pas de militante à lunéf première manif
en 2005 contre le CPE à votre arrivée à
Sciences Po c'est le choc des cultures
dites-vous votre moteur d'engagement la
volonté de faire bouger les choses et un
sentiment de révolte la politique pour
moi c'est ce qui m'a permis de sortir la
boule de rage que j'avais dans les
tripes en quelque chose de positif votre
marque de fabrique les coûts médiatique
dont vous avez le secret
[Musique]
vous ne presse vous faites souvent le
buzz mais vous l'assumez quitte à
déraper madame borne faut le dire vous
êtes une rescapé indignation dans la
classe politique le père de la première
ministre était un rescapé du
kandauschwitz accusé d'antisémitisme ce
jour-là vous plaît dès la maladresse des
polémiques mais aussi des victoires
lorsque l'assemblée adopte votre
proposition de loi sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
historique aujourd'hui
national parle au monde aujourd'hui
collègue notre pays parle au monde quant
à la nups vous en êtes l'un des visages
emblématiques cette coalition des
gauches parfois bien divisée sur sa
stratégie le communiste Fabien Roussel
parle d'une alliance dépassée et vous
Mathilde panneaux qu'en pensez-vous la
nupes a-t-elle du plomb dans l'aile
on va commencer par ça si vous le voulez
bien Mathilde panot cette déclaration de
Fabien Roussel qui juge la nupes
dépassée il faut rassembler bien au-delà
nous devons parler à toute la gauche
dit-il d'abord sur le fond c'est un
débat légitime selon vous débattre
aujourd'hui du périmètre de cette
alliance politique tout est légitime
mais moi je commencerai par noter
quelque chose la nupes elle est née en
13 jours et en 13 nuits suite aux
élections présidentielles et au choix
qui avait été fait par les électeurs et
les électrices et qui a permis de donner
cette alliance autour d'un programme de
gouvernement et ensuite c'est 151
députés de la nuit Pesse avec une
multiplication par 5 du nombre de
députés dans le groupe insoumis
donc depuis le premier jour on nous
explique que le lendemain et la semaine
d'après à chaque fois la nuit pèse va se
fissurer moi je note que depuis 9 mois
la nuit pèse se consolide mais je vais
dire là où j'ai eu un point de désaccord
très fort avec Monsieur Roussel sur
cette question c'est que quand il dit il
faut qu'elle s'élargissent
notamment avec Monsieur Cazeneuve qui
note et qui qui prend comme exemple là
je ne suis pas d'accord parce que nous
n'avons pas de coin commun avec Monsieur
Cazeneuve monsieur Cazeneuve je le
rappelle était ministre du Budget
lorsque le nombre d'annuités des
retraites a été
augmenté il était ministre de
l'intérieur lorsque Rémi Fraisse a été
tué et je le dis nous ce qui relie la
nupesse c'est un programme de
gouvernement et ce programme de
gouvernement compte un nombre de mesures
extrêmement forte et c'est autour de ça
que nous travaillons et que je crois
nous construisons quelque chose qui est
un espoir immense pour des millions de
gens ça c'est sur le fond sur la forme
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec vos alliés
communistes on a l'impression qu'il y a
vraiment des tensions extrêmes d'un côté
LFI de l'autre les communistes on a vu
des règlements de comptes sur Twitter
notamment Paul Vanier député LFI qui en
réaction propose à Fabien Roussel de se
consacrer à l'organisation de son
barbecue avec Bernard Cazeneuve et de
laisser la nupestre tranquille son petit
jeu de diviseur nous a déjà coûté le
second tour de la présidentielle ça
donne l'impression que vous avez du mal
à vous parler en interne à dialoguer
sans mettre tout sur la place publique
comme ça non je crois pas qu'on est des
problèmes avec des communistes mais
c'est vrai c'est un problème personnel
avec Fabien Roussel c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de dire régulier avec des
prises de parole de Monsieur Roussel qui
vont à l'encontre non seulement de notre
programme et de ce que nous essayons de
construire collectivement et je le dis
c'est une difficulté mais comme vous le
voyez depuis 9 mois nous avons fait un
nombre de propositions de loi avec
l'ensemble des groupes de la minute et
qui sont énormes en termes de travail
législatif à partir de notre programme
de gouvernement nous avons fait des
notions ensemble nous venons de déposer
une saisine à l'aide d'aller défendre
notre saisine au Conseil constitutionnel
ensemble donc peut-être
y a-t-il un problème avec Monsieur
Roussel je l'admets mais cela n'engage
en rien le fait que la nuit pêche
continue de se consolider et que je vois
plutôt que c'est du côté de la macronie
voir des LR que là vous avez des
divisions qui sont extrêmement fortes et
qui devraient vous inquiéter une
question tout donne sur la place que
prend la France insoumise dans les
décisions stratégiques de la nups à la
quand même été contestée récemment par
tous vos partenaires sur la réforme des
retraites sur le fait de refuser de
débattre de ce fameux article 7 qui
décalé l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite est-ce que vous assumez que
vous elle est fi première force
politique de la nupes doit pouvoir
imposer ses décisions aux autres
partenaires de temps en temps c'est pas
une question d'imposer des décisions
c'est une question que nous avons quatre
groupes dans dans l'inter-groupe et que
oui nous assumons que nous avons le
droit d'être maître de notre stratégie
en en 17 stratégie s'impose aux autres
c'est-à-dire votre stratégie c'est
imposée au communistes aux écologistes
au socialistes ça vient une différence
stratégique et je dois dire que je suis
assez fier que nous ayons réussi et ça
c'est pour le coup avec l'ensemble de la
nups à lever nombre de mensonges sur la
réforme des retraites notamment sur qui
toucherait les 1200 euros brut puisqu'on
est passé de tout le monde à 1,8
millions à 40 000 personnes puis
finalement à 10 à 20 000 personnes
seulement dans le pays qui toucherait
ses 1200 euros brut mais aussi que nous
nous ayons fait en sorte que ce texte
n'est aucune légitimité parlementaire et
je crois que c'est ce qui a permis de
donner du temps justement au mouvement
social de pouvoir s'organiser et quand
on voit ce qui s'est passé au Sénat je
crois que ça nous donne raison sur la
stratégie que nous avons eu j'aimerais
qu'on évoque à présent cette élection
législative partielle qui s'est déroulée
dimanche en Ariège et qui a vu la
députée sortante de la France insoumise
Bénédicte taurine battu par une
dissidente socialiste Martine Froget
alors la majorité présidentielle avait
appelé à voter en faveur de la
dissidente socialiste on a vu se
dessiner dans cette parcelle une sorte
de front anti LFI qui a fonctionné
quelles leçons est-ce que vous tirez de
alors là la première choses la première
chose c'est je veux quand même redire
ici mon affection à la fois pour
Bénédicte et l'ensemble des militants
qui ont mené une campagne d'une grande
unité là ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que évidemment
lorsque on a soit des tireurs dans le
dos soit de la division et bien cela
permet d'avoir effectivement quelque
chose qui se crée qui soit tout sauf les
filles mais il ne faut pas s'y tromper à
la fin c'est tout sauf la nuit peste
aussi qui se crée donc est-ce que c'est
pas aussi votre place au sein de la
nupaise votre capacité à rassembler
toute la gauche qui peut se retrouver
une remise en question par cette
stratégie on a le sentiment en fait que
vous avez tellement mis vos adversaires
sur les nerfs qui sont prêts à tout pour
vous faire battre je crois pas parce que
si Madame projet avait eu une réelle
étiquette macroniste il se serait passé
ce qui s'est passé au premier tour
peut-être avez-vous regardé les
résultats attentivement mais la
candidature macroniste au premier tour
est passé de 19 et demi en juin à 10%
seulement donc si elle avait une
étiquette Renaissance pure et dure et
bien elle n'aurait pas été élue donc je
le dis c'est que
que maintenant l'étiquette socialiste
n'est pas devenu plus rassembleuse que
ne pourrait l'être l'étiquette LFI
je ne crois pas et je crois que y
compris ce que nous construisons
ensemble avec la nupes doit alerter
chacun et chacune de se dire que nous ne
devons pas donner en quelque sorte des
permis de division à tout va et que
chacun des parlementaires de la nuit
parce que nous sommes sont concernés par
le fait que si il y a une candidature de
division qui se met et bien cela met en
cause à la fois le fait d'avoir des
députés de la nupesse mais aussi du coup
l'élection éventuelle de macronistes ou
encore pire de députés du rassemblement
national comme on l'a vu dans
l'hémicycle mais je dois vous dire
quelque chose quand même parce que quand
on fait le bilan des quatre législatifs
partielles qu'il y a eu depuis janvier
le résultat c'est denupès et -1 et Ren
voilà le résultat de ces élections et
notamment nous nous avons gagné René
Pilato qui a été élu en Charente donc je
ne crois pas non que vous puissiez tirer
des conclusions qui laissent à penser
que la France insoumise apparaîtrait
comme un en taille extraordinaire qui
ferait que on ne puisse pas être élu oui
donc quand sur une candidature il y a
une alliance et qui est manœuvrière
entre de renaissance jusqu'à l'extrême
droite puisque monsieur audoul c'est
félicité de la victoire de Madame projet
et bien oui à ce moment-là nous perdons
mais ce n'est pas ce qui se passe dans
ce que nous sommes une défaite ne va pas
du tout remettre en cause votre
stratégie qu'on peut appeler du bruit et
de la fureur dans l'hémicycle pour vous
il n'y a pas de lien entre les deux ça
ne va pas écouter les fraisiers elle a
fait 8 millions de voix à l'élection
présidentielle d'accord nous avons fait
22% et ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
parce que je vais vous expliquer ce qui
se justifie d'avoir à la fois un
programme de rupture ce que nous avons
avec la nupesse d'avoir à la fois une
crédibilité très forte parce que nous
avons des spécialistes sur tous les
sujets qui ont traduit en loi absolument
tout ce que nous avons proposé dans le
programme et qui montre que oui nous
sommes prêts avec la nupesse a remplacer
un gouvernement qui aujourd'hui à bout
de souffle et je l'espère même un
président alors sur la réforme des
retraites à présent la rencontre entre
Elisabeth borne et l'Inter syndicale à
Matignon a été un échec ce sont les mots
employés par les syndicats ce matin pas
question de retirer la réforme ni de
revenir sur les 64 ans cette réforme
elle a été adoptée le gouvernement ne
veut pas la retirer c'est quoi la suite
pour vous comment est-ce que vous
comptez maintenir la mobilisation
sociale en attendant la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel alors déjà je
veux saluer l'intersyndicale qui je
crois en quelque sorte faire un geste
fort au moment où la macronie cette
semaine a décidé d'essayer de tourner la
page de la réforme des retraites en
disant que c'était fini et qu'on allait
parler d'autre chose non on ne parle pas
d'autre chose quand c'est une réforme
qui va toucher la chair des gens la vie
des gens mais la suite c'est quoi pour
vous alors la suite évidemment c'est
demain là les normes mobilisation qu'il
va y avoir partout dans le pays et
j'invite toutes celles et ceux qui le
peuvent attendre avec des grèves qui
recommencent avec des piquets et des
blocages un peu partout donc ça c'est la
première chose et puis ensuite la
deuxième chose c'est que je vous disais
tout à l'heure nous avons fait une
saisie nos conseils constitutionnels
peut-être que c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel qui nous permettra de
sortir par le haut de l'impasse
démocratique dans lequel le Président
nous a placé parce que nous avons
d'excellents arguments pour dire que
cette loi est inconstitutionnelle et
j'espère que c'est la vie qui rendra le
Conseil constitutionnel en tout cas
c'est une nouvelle étape et cette lutte
va continuer quoi qu'il en soit d'un mot
la nouvelle secrétaire général de la CGT
Sophie Binet les relations entre les
filles et Philippe Martinez étaient
plutôt fraîches vous avez bon espoir que
les choses s'améliorent avec elle j'ai
écouté avec intérêt lorsqu'elle disait
qu'elle voulait normalisation des
relations avec les organisations
politiques et je pense que c'est
important puisque nous partageons un
objectif commun qui est le retrait de
cette réforme des retraites à 64 ans
merci ma petite